[Applause]
[Music]
before we get started let's just pay the
bills right now
[Music]
Main Street boxing gym this is all the
main street fighters come from 100% as
you can see there's a lot of bags full
size ring for your lipstick training a
lot of champions came in and out of this
place come here and train young and old
every bag imaginable
speed bag heavy bag full body bag full
size ring combat talk with the King now
we are here with the big one we have
triple G versus Canelo and this is the
second fight the first fight was to me
it kinda was action-packed was it a
memorable middleweight title fight in my
opinion no I felt that both fighters was
playing it safe time trying to you know
protect their their position in the
sport you know you have triple G but two
triple G's credit he had a hamstring
injury that was unreleased and that's
why he didn't cut off the ring properly
and you know in allegedly Canelo bulked
up and cut up on clutter ball and
dynabolt clutter Buland dynamo Oakland
literals you know allegedly all right so
you have two people that was trying to
protect their positions in HBO as well
as win
this is the caveat we have going into
this fight this fight
as far as holding in positions all bets
are off both guys contract with HBO ends
with this fight that being said this
fight will be leaps and bounds above the
last fight because these guys are
actually fighting for the future paydays
not you know not what you did in the
past
boxing is love loveless or sport where
it's you're only as good as your last
fight you're only as good as your last
win so if they're looking to cash out or
if they're looking to leverage where the
big money is out Heyman has definitely
uh he's partnered with us Fox and NBC
and CBS and the man has his hands all
over the place with Showtime and he has
a wealth of money and he hers has his
new network I think is DNZ in England
broad overseas where they gave him a
boatload of cash HBO has been on a
decline and HBO is the parent company
for Canelo and um triple G sorry
so with that said that's the caveat
going into this fight with that being
said I believe that this fight will be
leaps and bounds because of the
financial gains all losses
acute in this fight both guys weighed in
at the middle weight limit of 160 they
were 159 0.6 each whoa Canelo's 159
point for triple G was 150 nine point
six so they both came in they both made
weight training camps were good for both
no injuries to report so fighting styles
going into this fight as you may see
Canelo looks leaner he believes that to
be Co often you need movement and
he is right in this assessment in this
assessment you need to be in and out you
need to be able to maintain a high work
weight and also a high output rate as
far as movement darting in and out
defense stay conscious on defense they
keep your backs off the ropes and keep
them in the ring circle and turn triple
G same triple G cost a professional
Olympian all right now the an Olympian
cannot be understated you have to
understand being an Olympian means that
you fought people all over the world you
did not fight one style you did not
fight one crop of people you fought the
best from around the world and triple G
is an Olympian all right and that's why
he is as hailed as he is now in this
fight
I believe triple G would be better in
this fight as far as pressure riot wise
because the hamstring will not be
hampering him going into this fight
alright so the movement the ring cut
offs the body work the shop right hands
and the jab all should be working he
doesn't have a serious job as far as
Larry Holmes or a sugary minute jab he
has more of a prodding jab to get into
work type a jab so a more of a Roberto
durán type of jab okay it's a hard
forceful jab it's not a set up jab it's
a forceful jab to really put you in a
position where the body shot will come
not a body shot is more of a setup for
the right hand and a hook to the head
all right
so being that both guys make weight
being that at the weigh-in there was a
slight altercation at this point in time
I don't believe that was fake I believe
these guys truly don't like each other
accusations has been thrown from both
sides
as far as being greedy for triple G
being a drug cheat allegedly for Canelo
so both guys do not like each other
at all all right and it came out at the
weigh-in and it had to be separated now
does Canelo trying to go at triple G at
the weigh-in seem that he's gonna
puncture Pucci no these are fighters all
right and when you decide to fight and
you decide to take your life and put it
inside your hands to go out and fight
you're not afraid of anything
I don't ever believe a fight is afraid
of anything I believe the worst thing
that a fighter can do is lose money I
believe they're afraid of the next
payday being lost so that's why this
fight would be amazing
do I see Konoe low boxing for as long as
II think he's gonna box no there's two
different things to boxing sparring and
to move in sparring it's two different
things to boxing and jog and try to get
your stamina up when you're not in the
ring there's a mental pressure that goes
in the ring okay if someone is trapping
you and they're pressuring you there's a
added weight to that pressure how well
Canelo deals with that pressure will
determine the outcome of this fight
triple G will mount pressure triple G
will jab on his way in he will follow by
a right hand he will follow by the left
to the liver he will make sure that he
keeps him in front of him at all times
if Canelo gets on the ropes there will
be a high work rate from triple G Canelo
will use defense he has learned a lot
from his loss to Floyd Mayweather as far
as sliding slipping and he has to
hall-of-famers teaching him how to fight
do not under score this the two
hall-of-famers is Bernard Hopkins
probably the greatest middleweight in
middle rate history regardless of how
you feel
his record dictates so also Oscar De La
Hoya De La Hoya has learned a lot of
defense from Floyd Mayweather senior who
was in his corner for a couple of his
fights all right and you can also notice
the Canelo has started using that same
defense
when it comes to his fights I know
Bernard Hopkins showed him certain
things with the shoulder and the elbows
and is slipping and the pushing and the
moving in the mugging and how to drag a
fight and also put yourself in position
because it's footwork so when it comes
to this fight
I believe that again is gonna go 12
rounds but this time the outcome will be
concise it would be clear-cut because
the first fight ended in controversy
where everyone felt triple G won but you
know you could give Canelo some rounds
handy with stealing rounds like Sugar
Ray Leonard he thought if he bulked up
he'd be able to stand there and fight
with triple G he got a little bit tired
and arounds he wasn't able to fight full
rounds he was fighting in the beginning
1 minute of the round and 30 seconds at
the end didn't it shrunk into 30 seconds
in the beginning 30 seconds and end and
the middle was moving hugging holding a
pot shouting alright so this fight I
have triple G winning by a majority
decision um do we get a knockdown I
think he won't catch Cano McLean I think
Canelo will catch him clean with a lot
of shots I don't think we will get a
knock out the pedigree of these fighters
do not indicate anything of that
magnitude but again these guys are
fighting for the future paydays this is
combat talk with the king and we have
won tonight
[Applause]
[Music]